okay we're going to begin with breaking
news out of chat where the armies
announced president idris debbie has
been
killed the army says he was leading
soldiers fighting rebels on the front
line
debbie had just won re-election and was
one of africa's longest
serving leaders hiber morgan's joining
us now live from chad's capital in jama
heba what more do we know about what's
been happening
well rob what we do have right now is a
statement that came from the army itself
which is that
uh president debbie who's been running
the country for more than 30 years
and who was set to lead it for another
five years
passed away from injuries he sustained
over the weekend in the fight between
the government forces
and the rebel group known as the front
for change and concord in the northern
region of canaan
now let's go back to how this all
unfolded on april 11th on the day of the
election
uh where debbie was running for a sixth
term uh the rebels came in from libya
where they have a non-aggression pact
with the
uh libyan warlord khalifa after and
launched an attack on a government
station at the border region of tibesti
and then they went on to advance until
they reached the region of canaan which
is about 300 kilometers
from the capital in germany now the
statement from the army at the time was
that they had launched airstrikes
against the rebel groups to prevent them
from advancing
uh to the region of canada which is
where they were able to reach up until
on saturday of just this weekend uh
the government then went on to assure
the citizens who were panicking here in
the capital in germany that everything
was okay
and that there was no need to concern
and that the rebels will not reach the
capital
like they had announced and we also know
that uh president debbie himself went to
the front lines
along with top army officials to uh lead
the battles against uh the group
uh and announced later that at least 300
were killed and more than 140
were captured while the rest fled and
were being pursued by the government
military
now we hadn't heard from debbie uh over
the weekend we didn't hear from him
yesterday as well on the day
that the uh national electoral
commission announced that he had won the
uh election by nearly 80 percent uh we
we were expecting to hear a statement
from him uh to uh to to
assure his supporters and to uh
basically welcome the results of the
national electoral commission
that now will not be happening we know
that uh we just learned from the army
that he had sustained injuries during
that
battles over the weekend and those were
the reasons and the bad the
injuries were the reasons why he passed
away so he will not be leaving the
country for the next
five years obviously the news is just
coming out and we're trying to assess
what's going on but is there any sense
from where you are
of how the country is going to be
reacting to this
well the capital has been very tense rob
even before the announcement that their
president
has passed away over the past couple of
days with the announcement that the
rebels were advancing towards in germany
lots of stores around the capital were
closed people were mostly staying
indoors
because they were concerned about the
security situation that only increased
yesterday morning when they saw more
government troops
patrolling the streets saying that they
were worried that these are signs that
the government statements
that the rebels have been repelled and
that they were not advancing may not be
correct and that they could be some
threats to their safety so lots of
people opted to stay
indoors and lots of stores opted to
remain closed now last night we heard
celebratory gunfires
around the capital in germany despite
the army saying that that should not be
the case because of
the panic mode that the people were in
but we heard a celebratory gun fine
nonetheless
around the capital in germany today
things were quite normal in the morning
we've seen stores opening
people were out and about they seemed to
be a little bit more assured
after seeing that debbie was poised to
leave for another five years and that
the army has been repelled
as per the government statement we yet
to see how they will react to this they
were very assured
this morning they were in a panic mode
yesterday evening and yesterday morning
so things have been very fluid here in
the capital in germany
but thanks very much indeed that's
hibern talking to us from chad's capital
in jama i want to bring in
um ami didris whose life for us in abuja
has been covering this region for us for
for many years
um the the western countries have often
seen
idris debbie as really a key ally in the
fight against
um armed groups like boko haram for
example and of course
now the front for changing concord in
chat what do you think
is going to be the impact of this news
on the security situation in the region
well basically rob let's start with the
chad itself now succession battle starts
constitutionally the speaker of
parliament is supposed to take over
if the president is indisposed now
whether or not
that will happen uh it remains to be
seen because this is a country
that is um that has seen a lot of coups
a lot of rebellions uh internally within
its own military
and of course the rebellion in the north
as well now regionally
charges involved in peacekeeping
operations or operations against armed
groups
in the lake chart region in central
africa and other parts of
the region as well so chad for many
countries
in the region is an important ally in
the fight against uh
extremist group or armed groups that
have been operating in that region
for example china played a critical role
in displacing boko haram from its
territory last year
after an operation led by the president
himself just like the way he did in the
north
he led a force that dislodged boko haram
fighters and iso
fighters from the lectured region
freeing the territory of chad of these
attackers
and he's been a crucial partner for
nigeria a lot of chinese forces are
currently
are part of the multinational joint task
force working in nigeria working in asia
working in parts of cameroon
as well as other parts of the region to
keep ice swap and boko haram away
this will mean a very very tense
situation for the region
uh especially countries that are
struggling to deal with these armed
groups
so it's it's very very critical now
whoever succeeds
um child or mr president idris debbie
uh should quickly address the issue or
the vacuum that may likely arise in case
in
in in the in in the incidence of his
death now so
nigeria for example i know is very
worried uh it needs to
handle the situation very very well
currently we've seen an uptick in
violence in
the lectured region bordering child as
well as parts of
the northeast of nigeria apart from
nigeria chat or
republic also is dealing with an optic
in violence uh
crossing from mali into niger from
burkina faso
and cameroon also has its own share of
violence in
the recent past so this is a very very
tense moment for
all countries in the region that have in
one way or the other relied on child
for collaboration in dealing with armed
groups in the region
we were talking there ahmed about the
the uh succession process but we're just
seeing on chad tv
that the army is being quoted as saying
that a military council
is going to be handling that transition
now
given the fact that people in chad had
really hoped
that this was going to be the end of a
fairly prolonged political process and a
fairly strenuous one
how do you think that that news is going
to go down
for the politicians it's a very very
heavy blow to democracy whether or not
president idris debbie was a dictator
whether or not he manipulated
the electoral system that could spell a
very very
uh very very lethal blow to democracy in
that country
uh these uh army in a region where
military coups are so prevalent in the
recent past
this could mean that child will have to
wait a long time
for it to return to democracy fully we
suspect that this could take probably
three four years
unless of course there is international
pressure to hand over a democrat
to a democratically elected government
or some form of a transitional uh
civilian administration in the region
but for democracy in charge that should
be or that will be on hold for many
who know the uh the way things work in
that country but i know we're going to
be coming back to you in the next few
hours as we get more information about
what's going on but for now amit idris
thank you very much indeed